ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
timbaland show
episode
special episode here from
the gas digital network where everything
uh started for this show this major
massive media
operation started here in the bowels of
the east village at the gas digital
studio under the tutelage of louis gomez
a major media figure
like robert maxwell jizlane maxwell's
father was a media mogul lewis gomez
media mogul
uh under his tutelage
i started the tim dillon show massive
media
uh operation conglomerate
as many have referred to it and i can't
run away from that
anymore people have accused me of being
a powerful
figure in the media and i cannot run
away from that anymore it is facts are
facts i'm kidding of course am i
and uh because i got into a skirmish
and i i didn't even mean to do this i
i tweet all day every day
um
and uh
my tweets anger people to varying
degrees
and uh i was uh with ben and we were
driving back from rochester
new york and we were going to new york
city i didn't want to fly because it
dries out my throat even though my
throat still sounds bad imagine how much
worse it would have sounded had i flown
so it's a six hour
uh drive and that's a lot of uh keyboard
time a lot of finger time
for twitter
um
including an hour stop at the cheesecake
factory where do you remember uh i don't
know the name of that town oh oh it was
outside syracuse yeah right there and um
cheesecake factory
outside of syracuse new york
there was out of a lot of things they
were out of a lot of things but the
things we had were good the cheesesteak
the cheese cheeseburger
egg rolls
the quesadillas one of the best
in the industry uh
and
i tweeted about the sketch that snl did
uh where p davidson played joe rogan
and
somebody else played big bird uh kyle
mooney okay
and it was about it's again just kind of
recycling this
hack
premise that joe rogan took horse
medication for covin ivermectin
which isn't true it's like a widely
discredited thing right it's like a cnn
talking point like dnc
talking point it's weird
that you wouldn't go further with it
we've made fun of joe
we've made fun of ivermectin
there's a lot to make fun of with
podcasts whatever
alternative treatments there's tons of
things you can do
the sketch was admittedly
pretty lazy
and
i think
most people knew that
and i tweeted that
i said that i said that the show now is
kind of lazy mediocre hacks not every
sketch
not everything they do
certainly not everybody that works there
but
you know when they go political
they they it's low-hanging fruit they're
not trying to
do anything that makes you go wow
um
i mean the this is a show that did the
molar days of christmas on the first day
of christmas bob mueller gave to me
this is not it's a propaganda arm which
is okay right you're allowed to be that
comedy show should have a point of view
and i don't have to agree with it but
when it's so blatantly
uh state propaganda and it's so
blatantly lazy
and and it's not executed well at all
people can criticize it like that's you
know
something that's gonna happen
and i criticize it and then one of the
writers michael che who i never had we'd
never had a negative interaction ever in
our lives
um
you know came at me and was basically
like tim dillon's not what you think he
is
he's a sweet humble guy which i agree
with and then he goes he tried stand up
and got nowhere
and um
became a media personality because it's
much easier because became a media
personality because it's much easier
um
which again
is he's entitled to his opinion right i
have a platform and an opinion
and people care about what i say that
tweet got like 40 000
favorites and a bunch of retweets so i
listen
you know i don't even know what the
media is but i guess anyone with a
platform and opinions in the media
um
it's not harder to be in the media i
mean just let's say i am in the media
let me take that premise i don't know
that i agree with that he works for nbc
you would think if anyone was in the
media
i i it's me and you here i have nobody
behind me at all i'm except louis
maybe because he owns the studio but
this idea that i'm a major media figure
is kind of funny um
but again am i known from the podcast
sure is he known from snl yes
neither of us
really are like sebastian maniscalco
who's known from standup now we both do
stand up um but
and we're good at it i think he's funny
and i don't know what he thinks i am but
we sell thousands of tickets all over
the world um which he's not doing but
that's okay doesn't mean anything it
just means that there's people that
enjoy my stand-up and
that's what it is now maybe those people
don't matter that maybe they're all
nazis who knows that's possible it's
possible that everyone who's succeeding
is a nazi and all of their fan bases are
nazis and that's the only reason that
anyone is successful at all perhaps
dozier cat is a nazi and everyone that
buys tickets to her shows are nazis if
you have a live event and it sold over
70 of tickets it's very possible
everyone there loves hitler i guess i
don't know that seems to be the running
explanation for why anyone is successful
at anything um
and that was his uh uh tweet and then i
think i i tweeted back
um you know some some things
that i felt were true that are true
um
and again i don't even especially
dislike michael che i think he's
smart in the sense that
he's
you know usually on the right side of
issues i think he understands comedy he
defends comedy a lot he gets into
arguments with some of the same people
that
i would get in an argument with but you
know
i i don't know where that came from i
can only imagine that you know he knows
that that sketch wasn't great
what i said kind of got under his skin
again not meant to just an observation i
was making
and he got mad at that and was like tim
dill's not what you think he's not some
truth teller i don't know what even he
thinks people think i am the sketch
wasn't good
so if pointing out the sketch was good
uh you know makes me
i mean then everybody
uh whatever every i mean you got to do
that for everyone that saw this catch
they're not what you think they are
this random guy he's not what you think
he is
there are people that are fans of us
another one that's not good
um and then i just kind of said i said
listen i the reality is i sell more
tickets than
che ever has
um he's not allowed to be on twitter
because of his job which is true so i
didn't tag him or anything um
and then i said i built something on my
own that he never could i it is of my
belief that he probably could not have i
don't know maybe he could have
um and then i said you know he's done
well for uh wait what did i say he said
che has done well for a drunk who can
barely read but his show sucks and he
knows it and that's true and those are
you know that's great and i again
he's gonna say i'm not a comedian i'm
gonna say things about him it's kind of
a petty silly
thing
um
you but
at the end of the day it all comes down
to the fact that
i angered some people over there or
maybe just him
with a tweet
that was a pretty innocuous observation
compared to other things that i've said
um
and hey
this idea that people that are
succeeding on the internet are not
comedians
is an idea that is meant to
um
justify the lack of success
people are having in mainstream spaces
so when nobody on snl or very few people
on snl can sell any tickets excite
anybody
uh their given shows they're given
budgets to do sketch shows that nobody
watches
um
none of them none of the sketches go
viral as many of our things have gone
viral they're not really a voice in the
conversation that matters other than
when they do the big show every saturday
night and they all come together
and they make some noise and usually the
noise is people going god this is bad
that's usually why it gets any attention
um but individually that show is really
not launching people
into orbit anymore the way that it used
to
and i've defended the show it's probably
the singular most important comedy
platform uh in america in terms of the
amount of talented people that have come
out of that show
to go into
uh film and movies that have defined
really what comedy is in the 20th
century
and
i've laughed at things they've done
i mean a week ago last week right i
don't
i don't think that we go more into this
on the patreon with ray just because it
just happened um coming out thursday
yeah coming out thursday but it's never
my intent
to be uh
antagonistic to people now i do attack
them weekly viciously
truly and it isn't my intent to be
antagonistic it's my intent to help
it's my intent to help truly and i mean
you may not believe that but i i would
like the show to be better i don't want
to be on the show i don't need their
money i'm okay
what i would like is to help i want it
to be better
it is it is some of the things are are
good
some of them could get better i am just
saying hey
this is what it is from one member of
the media to another member of the media
michael j we're all members of the media
buddy
i don't know what you're talking about
stand-up comedy huh
it's the media
go ask a 15 year old go hey what's who's
your favorite stand-up they'll say uh
cody ko
because cody's a famous guy on the
internet the only things people really
care about now are things that they can
share with other people and if you don't
think my podcast is funny or you know
there are people that say i love your
stand-up there's people that say i love
the podcast there's people that love
both there's people that go i don't like
stand-up but your podcast makes me laugh
um
drawing lines around one kind of funny
is weird to me i've never looked at a
writer and went yeah look like david
sedaris writes a lot of funny books i've
never been like yeah but what are your
views like
you don't do [ __ ] on instagram it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter to me he's funny there
are people that are funny right um
but that's that's really all i have to
say about that i ironically
uh
uh i'm gonna start submitting packets
for snl
just for fun
to see if uh they'll hire me i'm
actually gonna call my agent and ask him
if there's a shot now they never do this
but is there a chance
that they would hire me
in the middle of the season rarely done
maybe never done i don't know
um as a consultant and they could kind
of bring me in to the writer's room and
we could uh
hash it out
the chances of that happening are very
low
and i know that um
but again you know not everyone's gonna
like you in this right and i i and
that's fine
um
and uh not everybody's gonna value
the the media empire that we've built
here the very
wide-reaching
influential
media empire it's a weird it's a weird
way to insult somebody by going like
they're
they're a media figure like i thank you
i don't think so but
i appreciate it
um
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help you in the bedroom
especially when it comes to step up the
plate step up to the plate that's where
bluetooth comes in bluetooth unique
online service that des delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost you can take them
any time dare nights you can plan ahead
be ready whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package i love blue
chew men everywhere are excited to see
the post man first impressions are
important what about lasting impressions
it's time to get off the couch and get
back to work on [ __ ]
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners okay
uh try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code td at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's b-o-u-e shoe.com
promo code td to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
we thank bluechu for sponsoring the
podcast this is a great way to support
the show and support your dick do it
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and tim dylan show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
tim d
better help is great do you need help
but you don't want to leave your house
and the help that you need may not be
available to you in the places that you
live well you can start using better
help but it's not a crisis line it is
not a self-help it's professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise available
that may not be locally available where
you live you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses from your counselor
and if you're not hitting it off with
your counsel you can transfer your
counselor any time
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselors if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today they've got thousands of crazy
good reviews better help people have
taken charge of their mental health with
the help of an experienced professional
better help they're recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
better h-e-l-p
get 10 off your first month tim d baby
you know it
the the new movement now that i got to
take these these headphones are like
this is i love this but this is real gas
digital stuff the headphones are
kind of in and out let's try them again
okay they're better now okay louis likes
to keep everybody on their toes here
there's only there's only there's some
real talent on the network for sure
uh but then there's always i still call
lewis all the time i go there's a lot of
shows have to go
because i still keep track of everything
you know
ralph now is just running like 12 miles
a day and no one cares
all ralph does ralph is the co-owner of
gas digital all ralph will do is like
update everybody he's like i ran eight
miles today midtown ralph who gives a
[ __ ]
like we get it you lost weight and you
can run
we appreciate that just finished nine
miles i ran down by the brooklyn navy
yard hey ralph cut it out
i just made roasted chicken in an air
fryer and now i'm gonna run we hey we
get it
good maybe he had a health scare i don't
know did ralph have a health scare was
that what this was about shannon no he
just gained a bunch of weight and then
during the pandemic started running
smart because he's really made a change
now
and uh
be funny if you get hit by a car
[Laughter]
jogging
just healthy
just with the taste of brussels sprouts
still in his mouth
um
yeah
so i wanted to talk about this article
because i thought this was a very
interesting article this is a movement
that i should know more about and i
don't know more about it and it's called
the anti-work movement and this is a
movement of people who are leaving the
workforce for good not temporarily not
because they're
you know uh
you know
taking a moment to regroup these are
people that are out they're done they
don't want to come back and that's kind
of interesting
uh that they've had that epiphany
over the last 12 months and they've
decided that it's not
a specific job they don't like it's any
job it's they don't want to do anything
and there's part of me that respects
that i can really kind of get into that
but then what do you do on like day
three of that it's
you know day one and two were all
planned out and then day three you start
going wait a minute
a lot of humans get self-worth from
their job i know that that
is a terribly controversial thing to say
now
um and i know that people think
that if humans were freed
from the need of having to work then
they would just be beautiful magical
creatures that would you know during the
pandemic everybody was like well if
people didn't have to work they would go
out and start community gardens and they
would do this and do that and okay
during the pandemic everybody was off
i didn't see any community gardens
i didn't really see anyone planting
anything and i'm not saying people
should work in these shitty conditions
and not get paid and get ripped off
which is what's happening and i'm not
saying you should have this massive
chasm between certain people that work
and other people that work in terms of
how much they get paid
but the idea that you could get rid of
all work is interesting to me i don't
want to discount it immediately but i
know a lot of people that don't work and
aren't doing well
and i don't mean just financially i mean
in every conceivable way
friends of mine that don't work are on
the internet all the time way too much
almost as much as me and it's my job
um they don't seem happier they're not
in better relationships because they
don't work they don't have better
relationships with their family they're
certainly not planting any community
gardens they're not doing much in their
community at all friends i know that
don't work kind of become angry
paranoid people that spend all their
time online
figuring out why it is that they feel
the way that they do
this is my own personal experience
in the same way that friends of mine
that work too much are also kind of
anxiety-ridden
miserable people
so there's a balance but let's talk
about this article it's interesting
there's a guy that move it's from a
business insider
that's the rag
that just ran that hit piece on davey
portnoy
and they were gonna run a hit piece on
me and one comic this kid was an open
mic comedian who quit
then went to work for business insider
interviewed me i was down in florida he
called me i spoke to him for an hour you
know
you know the question you know alex
jones and you
did a podcast together
what was that about
what was it like
where are you
you say some things the anger people
why do you do it
what is it about
and i sat there in a parking lot smoking
cigarettes
suffering through this interview because
nobody asks any good questions
where are you from
were you always a contrarian
did you know alex jones when you were a
baby
they're the worst questions ever because
journalists are stupid they're not and
they're not journalists
journalists are people who have white
hair and [ __ ] in libraries and look at
microfiche and they try to solve the
kennedy assassination shannon knows
we've had them on the show they have no
money no one buys their books no one
cares and they die alone and unfulfilled
those are journalists or they go to like
a war-torn country they run around that
country people shoot at them they get
some guy to give them some story at a
cafe they win a pulitzer prize a year
later no one cares they get diagnosed
with cancer because they were too close
to like live ammunitions and they die
alone and unfulfilled this is what
journalists are
and then you have stenographers meaning
that they just write down things the
government wants them to say those
people have big houses they're on tv a
lot they write books that are always put
out there they're in the front of the
bookstore and it's like uh it's just a
picture of uh you know god only knows
you know winston churchill or fdr and
they're like they wrote a history of him
which someone else wrote they just kind
of grabbed it it's ghost written they
said the greatest generation you know
tom broke or any of those guys and their
books are pushed because they don't make
any trouble they don't cause any
problems and they're you know and they
lie you know like brian williams the guy
who just made things up and he lies and
they all lie because no one catches them
and lying is like a drug you get
intoxicated with doing it if nobody
catches you and that's so those are the
class of journalists and then you have
these like new york
media types who like write for these
glorified blogs
and they don't have any money and they
eat ramen and they live on the floor
and they have a degree from like
syracuse university or some other
embarrassing school oh the new school of
journalism is good who cares uh or
colombia which is an ivy or whatever and
they're at these people are so mad that
they don't have talent they're so and so
they love other people that don't have
talent so they love unfunny comedians
they love it and they write stories like
who's the next [ __ ]
because they have no talent they go
where can i go to find people that like
me
are incredibly deficient in any
noticeable skill
and they find them and they go these are
25 comedians that you're gonna know
and they get in this little group of
people
and no one cares and they don't have any
money and they get angry at people like
dave portnoy uh because he he's again
has a media operation and he's taking
eyeballs away from people like cnn from
espn and bigger
um uh platforms that are losing eyeballs
to barcelona sports in the same way that
our patreons like the number two in
america there are people that lose
eyeballs and ears or whatever to us
because they enjoy this show so the new
york media types and it's not oh and i
don't mean jews
and i don't so don't tweet at me
and and because there's a lot of
christians doing this too shamefully and
probably a few scientol i'm kidding the
scientologists are they've they figured
it out
but the new york media because new york
is the media capital of the world these
people are oh they always have it out
for people like rogan and because these
guys are threat independent
operations are threats they're big
threats that's why i don't run away from
the media you can call me media all day
i don't really care
um i think it's
uh funny media if i am media you just
also have to be media sitting at a desk
with a suit on working for
nbc and the saudi royal family you also
have to be considered me if i'm media
your media we're all media baby
so this comic calls me what's it like to
be yeah
and then i answer all the questions then
i forget about it completely because i
don't care about it and business
insiders is uh you know is a rag but
we're going to talk about their
anti-work article but a lot of people
have this article the guardian whatever
this is the one
that caught my eye it's a wreck and they
write inflammatory stuff like this
article is kind of like no one's there's
a movement because this is meant to piss
off people that are working they write
an article like this you're like
nobody's working anymore you are sucker
and and dave portnoy's gonna spit in
your daughter's mouth
tomorrow dave portnoy's choking your
daughter today how does that make you
feel you got a wife well dave pornoy's
choking her he's choking women and damn
talking he's running around nantucket
grabbing every woman he sees at the
farmer's market and spitting down the
throat untrue doesn't seem to be what's
happening okay i did go to barcelo
sports and he spit my mouth it was a bit
i think it was a joke i don't know he
spit my mouth and said pig and then
walked away it was jarring but not
entirely unexpected and it was somewhat
enjoyable
he
uh
has kind of proven they were after him
this comic calls me
uh the day
the portnoy stuff breaks and he goes hey
i quit insider because they wouldn't run
a hit piece on you i don't know if
you've wondered why the piece has never
come out and i said i haven't wondered
that because i don't care i don't really
know who you are and i was like the
eating sushi parked in a handicapped
spot outside of bristol farms and i was
more concerned with that and he goes
well it didn't come out because they
they wanted me to run a hit piece on you
and i said on me
they want to run a hit piece on me
and yes they wanted to run a hit piece
on me and say i was some reactionary
right wing lunatic nut jump you know the
way these people operate
so
i'm
not too shocked by what happened to dave
and what will happen to anyone
if you have an opinion that runs counter
when everybody says that coveted kids
should be uh doxxed and you go hold on
the facts are that the kids are standing
there they're getting yelled at by black
israelites
a guy walks up to them starts beating a
drum in his face the kid just smiles
it's a pretty
tame reaction
getting in a teenager's face i can think
of a lot of people that would have had a
crazier reaction the kid just stand
there and smiled and for that the entire
u.s media wanted to ruin the kid's life
to make a point
okay now the written house seems a
little more complicated but it's still
clear
that it was a self-defense that he
reasonably believed that his life uh was
threatened that doesn't mean he should
have been there with an ar-15
17-year-olds that have no training
should not be patrolling the streets
with ar-15s his mother is a psychopath
my mother would not drop me off at the
mall
uh if she was busy this woman dropped
her son off at a riot with a gun
and was like good luck son
that is not good parenting it's
poor parenting and the kid's a confused
kid who wants to be a good kid whatever
that means in his head
by the way people that join gangs want
to be good people want to be good they
want to be they want to have uh you know
they want to be like important and they
want to serve a function and that's why
people join all kinds of groups and
that's why he said i'm going to patrol
the streets with these other yahoos and
this is why you can't have
chaos and political violence in the
streets all the time
and again he's a media figure this is
media that he's doing it's uh common
sense to say we shouldn't have people
running around in the streets killing
each other
that is my controversial opinion of the
week that we shouldn't
now people can get angry today no it's
more complicated than that
you're a psychopath how dare you say
that
i'm saying
that no matter the reason i don't
believe the best course of action is to
have people in the streets
killing each other
uh and burning things down and writing
there's a better way to do it it's
called civilization it's a better way to
do it okay
that's
the dog whistle for white supremacy
civilization how dare you say it
but
gritting house is a nut and please and i
you know we talked about this on the
patreon but like the last thing i need
is him
getting off and then three days later on
twitter tweeting at me
and taking my side in the michael j
thing kyle please do not
please i'm asking you for me
selfishly
take his side please take his side if
you're gonna take his side and it's over
there are no
there are no sides but
you know
if you have an opinion that runs counter
to what people want the opinion people
want you to have people just
are going to get out get angry at you
upset
call your names whatever so the
anti-work article is interesting this is
uh from uh insider great publication
and what does this say what are people
doing here it says inside the rise of
anti-work a worker strike that wants to
turn the labor shortage into a new
american dream
this is like the article that bloomberg
ran that said hey the stores don't have
any stuff in them maybe that's good
and you know bloomberg the guy who runs
bloomberg is mike bloomberg
billionaire look at mike bloomberg's net
worth it's like 70 billion or more
this is the guy that ran for president
uh 59 billion wow well he's in the
middle class i forgot
59 billion dollars
he runs the publication and bloomberg is
saying they have this article you should
find the article where it's basically
like hey americans may need to live like
europeans and that's pretty damn cool
maybe that's not the worst thing that
you go to the store and the
shelves are half full
yeah supply chain shortages are
constraining you as consumers endless
appetite for buying whatever they want
whenever they want it's about time yeah
like eggs
the endless appetite for
things after all americans haven't
always acted like this we've entered an
age of overabundance we consume much
more than we used to and more than other
countries so they're kind of shaming us
and too well here's the deal
we absolutely consume too much we're too
fat we eat too much the houses are too
big everything's too big
but
the way to fight that probably is some
type of spiritual renaissance where
people realize that consumption in and
of itself is uh ultimately empty and
hollow and then they need to involve
themselves in more meaningful activities
where they can get more out of life uh
that's the hard way to do it and the
sustainable way uh just walking into a
store and not having things
doesn't seem like a real
people are still gonna consume just
whatever they can find
these are also the people that go
uh fat is great you eat whatever you
want whenever you want it and then
they're like maybe americans should
start living like europeans well you
know what that means not being fat slobs
but i thought that was good
fatness is good it's not unhealthy don't
think it being 500 pounds is healthy and
great and beautiful and everybody will
how do you get to be 500 pounds
consuming [ __ ]
so if you say well we should stop
consuming what do you mean by that do
you mean americans should stop buying
treadmills
no you mean the people should like hey
how about one loaf of bread for the week
for the family that's kind of how i read
it
you don't need all the new gadgets and
gizmos
a lot of them food related
but
it's weird to get this article from
bloomberg
it's weird to have a bunch of
billionaires go yeah the stores are bare
the prices of gas is up so just drive
less
hey you can't afford gas maybe you
should uh don't go there that place you
want to go
why don't you go to hey you want to go
see your mother c or less
it's very condescending and strange to
tell people that they should adjust
their habits when billionaires and
people worth hundreds of millions of
dollars have only gotten richer have
only bought more jets
have only bought more property can only
do more things
and people that aren't in that bracket
can't do anything and those people are
told it's good they they tell people to
go on long bike rides rather than just
drive because go on a bike ride with
your kids
on the highway
take your children on a bike ride on the
side of the road and go to the grocery
store it's good for you maybe you'll all
die
and we could stop here in your mouths
whitney webb's coming back on to talk
about this the great reset
and i know that a lot of people have
dismissed that as a conspiracy and maybe
parts of it are but saying that this is
uh restructuring the economy is not a
conspiracy it seems pretty damn accurate
read a paragraph or two of this article
about what's going to happen in the
world when nobody works well this is a
new lifestyle the work free lifestyle is
what they call it great a rising mood
i'm excited
i've been living it for years
so this is how it starts it says
larry had a vision shannon remembers
when i used to have a job i used to come
in with a tour bus jacket from giving
tours on a double-decker bus and then i
would come do the podcast shannon
remembers that
and i would come in every day and think
i had like a new disease
and i would google
and i burned my mouth and then i googled
like sore mouth and it would say like
you have
you know some like
you know a disease
that's only transmitted by the south
african baboon spider and i'd be like
[ __ ]
because i work does make you lose your
mind a little bit so i'm in the middle
here i'm not crazy work but i don't know
if we
you know maybe we should do something
this is how it begins it says
larry had a vision after he graduated
college he and his then wife were going
to be a power couple they were going to
actualize their american dream they'd
buy a house in the suburbs and go on
vacation every two years that's not a
power couple larry you dumb [ __ ]
the clintons are a power couple jeffrey
and jazlene are power couples you just
wanted to be ordinary regular americans
see this is my problem with everything
nobody questions anybody's premises so
immediately we're starting out with a
guy who's probably crazy because he
thinks a power couple is a couple that
can afford coffee in the suburbs that is
not true if the article had started
larry when he graduated college wanted
to be a power couple he wanted to grab a
woman that he wasn't sexually attracted
to get married for money rise through
the ranks of the corporate world and
then eventually go into politics all the
while uh participating in many nefarious
activities including uh the rape torture
and sacrifice of young children in order
to build loyal bonds with other members
of said class at that point larry and
his wife would begin to redesign
themselves as folksy nationalists who
just cared about america all the while
going home and eating the flesh of
children in his stew
that would make sense so what did he
want to do he wanted to work and live in
the burbs well why wasn't he able to do
that well he was a maintenance
technician in south carolina and uh so
the vision of the perfect life
eventually shattered
where's his wife
uh she's from colorado right but keep
reading okay his in-wife saw through the
illusion of work he said and quit to
take care of their children and her
elderly father it took him a little
longer to get there
uh let me scroll down here uh so now it
says keep reading when he got laid off
from a seasonal job there he moved back
to south carolina to be with his mother
now he lives simply and a 20-foot
trailer in the backyard what about the
kids and the wife
uh the kids and the wife
uh ex-wife and children are in colorado
right now it seems like okay
so what's interesting about this is like
you forget he has a wife and kids like
he's like i just i'm a simple man
with simple pleasures and i just go and
i want to live with my mother it makes
it sound nice but he left his wife and
children yes yeah and he's choosing to
not support his kids it seems that way
he's choosing to not support his wife
and kids and we this was celebrated
as a new movement and work and they're
like gen v has defined this new movement
of giving the power back to the workers
no it's called being a deadbeat dad it's
not a new movement it's pretty [ __ ]
old ask louis about it
his dad got stabbed that's not
technically his fault but his mom did
smack but his mom kind of raised him
pretty well for someone who was on
heroin she did like a good job but my
point is that being a deadbeat dad is
not like a new thing i read this article
they're trying to dress this up as like
this is a new revolutionary balance of
power shift between employer employee
this isn't a guy that unionized his job
and got more benefits for people there's
a guy that said i don't like my children
and wife i want to go live in a trailer
and drink
yeah it said i doubt he supports them
because it says here he says i don't
have any expenses i don't need any money
i can survive without it right i don't
have any expenses [ __ ] those kids
and they write about this like this is a
great new thing
living in a trailer with your mother is
good
the article has written that this is
this is what they want
understand who writes these articles
they're the they're dumb they're
journalists they're idiots but the
people that own these publications put
all this out for like a reason
they're like it's good to not work it's
good to live in a trailer with your
mother it's great when you go to the
grocery store and there's nothing there
to eat now you're living like a european
isn't this great they ran that article
in the beginning of the pandemic to go
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
isn't it great you have nothing and you
live with your mother in a trailer and
your family is gone and you don't have
any money to give them christmas
presents and [ __ ] christmas anyway
that's some capitalist horseshit you
just stay in your trailer and every now
and then wander to the grocery store
we'll give you a voucher for food that
won't be there anyway isn't it good now
you live like a european and europeans
don't live like that by the way
europeans work not all of them but like
they go to the cafe they get food they
smoke cigarettes they have sex they
don't like me too so if you want to
really be european you got to stop with
the horseshit women in europe like
getting thrown against a wall that's a
fact as long as you have like a nice
pasta dinner and everything they enjoyed
france literally came out joined me too
and went no we don't do that here we
like me too
we enjoy it cut it out we like [ __ ]
and not working so in america in this
sexless autistic horror culture that
we've created the only thing to do
literally is work we have a sexless
autistic horrible culture
that issues any type of like
family
or bonds outside of work so we're
telling people don't have families don't
[ __ ] each other don't do anything and
also don't work
well larry goes i really don't want to
work anymore i don't want to have any
meetings no deadlines no goals no
quarter no seminar i don't want none of
that stuff no more oh well that sounds
lovely
maybe it's not good that we have a
culture where people are just built to
work but if you want to start living
like europeans understand that their
culture is about family which we don't
[ __ ] have
we take our elderly people we throw them
in nursing homes where people beat them
as soon as we're of age we run away from
our families i know i did
to get successful in europe they live
with their families the family's a thing
the family name matters
people [ __ ] and have children in america
people have one child when they're like
40.
the kid's a furry
the parents are like insane
that's not
that then you gotta work
what are you gonna do go home and deal
with your furry kid
your kid who's a furry
and you and your kids only a furry
because you're working so much you don't
even know what the hell is going on in
their life
so then you got to go back to work
you're like i've already [ __ ] this one
up this one's a furry yeah in europe
they're lazy
slothful people that enjoy life because
they [ __ ] eat carbs
go on for the rest of this okay so
here's the retort from one moderator of
the subreddit he says a lot of people
mistake anti-work for being lazy and
like nothing ever has to get done says
uh rock cellist
but the truth of the matter about
anti-work and everything surrounding it
is that obviously things have to get
done but the current structure in which
things get done and the way that capital
flows as they get done is unfair and
should be non-existent well it's unfair
but the idea of it being non-existent is
a bit of a stretch
i don't exactly how exactly does that
work it's non-existent let's just get
rid of it in favor of what
right what exactly would be
what exactly would be the other option
you know
i think it's unfair and i think there's
ways to make it more fair
there's another person who left their
job because they couldn't take out their
phone yeah so cade a gen z worker in
kansas is one of the people who turned
ant r
yeah with a k
he turned to r slash anti-work and
posted after he quit his job as a
service worker he had been considering
coding for a while but he was pushed
over the edge after his boss posted a
sign telling workers they couldn't use
their phones during shifts what what a
tyrant by the way i love these words he
was pushed over the edge because a
worker said get off your phone and work
like a boss a boss said get off your
phone and work and he's like this is he
thinks it's a grapes of wrath
i mean this is
this is insane
i never really because he can't go a
whole day without looking at furry porn
he's watching furries [ __ ]
and the boss is like get
get him a coffee
or whatever
kate says i never really see anybody not
doing work and on their phone he added
he didn't think management should have
the right to take his personal property
so then he started seeing posts from our
slash anti-work a few months ago and
that reading people's accounts of
quitting and learning about the ways
their rethinking work factored into his
own decision to quit
he's already had at least one interview
for a new job and has a little bit of
savings built up to keep him afloat in
the meantime
good for you kade
kade we stand with kate says i think it
felt like i could be like a bigger part
of a movement
this is i mean this really is a movement
to these people it's a movement they're
a million strong
yeah they'll be more than a million
strong soon
nobody will work
though everybody will be
i just i just love the idea i love all
these articles that are all coming out
together work's bad because by the way
work means you have money money means
you don't have to listen to what the
government tells you to do
that is no good they don't want that
and if you question anything about the
covent thing now you're treated like
you've said hey did the holocaust really
happen
that's the response you get from people
people call me all the time they go i
just got my booster and i'm like are you
taking your mask off they go no
and i go why
they go well it's not safe and i go well
you just got the booster and they go
yeah but you don't know how long that
protection lasts you can still get it
and you can still get very sick you can
still go to the hospital and then go
right
now
do you understand how crazy you sound
they go no
like well how many more boosters will
you get as many as it takes for what
like there's no end goal seemingly
there's no end goal here this is the
problem i got vaccinated early on
i was like hey let's do it let's go back
out who cares
covers a holocaust of fat people
okay i'll get vaccinated i got
vaccinated then they said put the mask
on
the vaccine doesn't do what we wanted it
to do
and then they said well we never said
that it stopped you from getting it you
did
you did i have the receipts you
absolutely did you also said that if you
got it it wouldn't even be symptomatic
it'd be very mild that is not true
either we have those receipts then you
said well you won't go to the hospital
if you have it and you're vaccinated i
know people that have
and now the last thing is well you won't
die
don't you not want to die
it's like the last by the way this is
your parents
using everything on you and then finally
the last
uh ditch effort of a parent who's like
yelling at a kid usually is to go
some people die do you want to die
if i let you borrow the car you're going
to die and you go what
do you want to die you go no
so i'm not saying the vaccine is bad or
that you shouldn't get it what i'm
saying is that i'm confused and by
airing these questions in public i have
drawn the ire of many
i'm confused as to what the end game is
why
do we have to keep taking a thing that
isn't
doing
what we want and why mandate that people
have it
and fire people in mass if you can still
get it and spread it if vaccinated
people have far less likelihood to go to
the hospital with covid and far and
they're far less likely to suffer severe
consequences from it
then the people that are vaccinated
should be protected
and not require everyone else to be
vaccinated
um so it's weird to me but
if that isn't the case and people that
are vaccinated can still have all of
those things happen and all and and it's
not really less likely
viral load and vaccinated and
unvaccinated people is kind of similar
an article just came out i don't
understand the rationale
for the mandates which are
disproportionately affecting
uh black and hispanic people that don't
want to get the vaccine
as of the recent numbers i don't know
things may have changed but
so i've questioned those two things i've
never said that all vaccines are bad i
never said it was aborted fetal tissue i
never said you were gonna turn be a
zombie when the 5g you know but you're
treated like that if you ask any of
these questions no you're double vaxxed
you got both
well i'm fully fully blocked back say
you got to both shots yeah and i'm and i
had to covet so that should you know
twice and i'm not saying that like
everyone shouldn't get a booster i'm
going
what's the plan i'm just asking
questions hey
what are we when do the masks come off
when do kids not wear masks in school
when are we
because adults have gotten vaccinated
and we're still wearing masks in many
situations
so you go well if the kids are
vaccinated they won't have to wear masks
well why do i have to wear a mask
shut up
that's
why did you storm the capitol
what
there's something weird and there's
something weird in people's eyes right
now it's a little salem witch trials
it's a little iraq war 2003. it's a
little like don't question what we're
doing or you're gonna be out
if you question anything we're doing
we're gonna kill you
and that to me is a little
scary
and i've just said hey
leave me be let me live
ship station the holidays are the most
wonderful time of the year but if you're
running an online store and you know
they can also be the craziest with
everything's going on right now you need
to make sure that you're focusing on
growing your business and not the back
office stuff you've got inventory to
manage orders to fill and a growing list
of stressed out customers checking in
twice a day wondering whether those last
minute gifts will arrive in time with
ship station the hassle of shipping out
holiday orders melts away leaving you
with happier customers and more freedom
to run your business or enjoy some much
needed time off okay i love shipstation
the ease of how
it is it is easy to use
the money you save
i love it i have friends that use it
they run online e-commerce businesses
they use shipstation and they never have
to worry about anything my friend almost
got hit by a car because she was so not
worrying about anything
if you sell anything online i don't need
to tell you that shipping can be super
frustrating so many carriers ton of
factors that go into figuring the best
rate for each order easily import orders
from every sales channel whether it's
amazon ebay etsy or your own website and
automate just about any shipping task
from one easy to use dashboard changing
your shipping solution can seem daunting
with the holidays here now it is time to
think about making a change make this
holiday season a little brighter with
ship station use my overcoat tim dillon
to get a 60-day free trial just enough
time to handle the holiday rush just go
to shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top enter the code tim
dillon make ship happen
i love being safe at home do you
do you i do i use this simply safe ben
uses it
we use it i have it simply save is great
they install indoor and outdoor cameras
why'd you laugh the way you said camera
camera
comrade comrades
comprehensive sensors all monitored
around the clock by trained
professionals who send help the instant
you need it simply safe was even named
the best home security system of 2021 by
us news and world report you can easily
customize the system for your home in
minutes even get free custom
recommendations from simply safe these
are simply safe's biggest discounts of
the year
you can get a complete home security
system starting at just over a hundred
dollars that's crazy
there are no long-term contracts or
commitments it's really easy way to
start feeling a bit more peace of mind
take advantage of simply safe's holiday
sale and get forty percent off your new
home security system by visiting simply
safe dot com slash tim dillon again
that's simply safe dot com slash
timberland for 40 off your entire system
hurry this offer ends soon please what
other articles did you bring up uh uh
just lane just launched elaine's trial
starts today
now drizzling
may be guilty
i don't want to believe that
i don't want to jump to a conclusion
but it is harder and harder
to ignore
the mountains of evidence
that suggests
that gizlane maxwell
and i mean folks
it pains me to say this
i don't even want to say it
it pains me to say
there is evidence that suggests that
jizzlyn maxwell
and jeffrey epstein were running
a child trafficking ring
for very wealthy and powerful
people and members of the government
just started to accept that this may
have been what's happening
also it's possible that jeffrey epstein
didn't kill himself
that he was killed
so that he would not reveal
any of the people participating in said
trafficking ring
because by the way what i'm doing now is
a joke this is what the media will do in
a few months
the media will do this the media will go
in what is seeming to be a new
development
evidence is pointing to the fact
that jeffrey and chislane were running a
trafficking ring
and then they're gonna have to say
because if this is a real trial which it
may not be
there's speculation that epstein was an
asset it was an intelligence asset of
israel in the u.s or whatever some
hybrid
maxwell's father was a massage agent
um
widely known
book about it by seymour hirsch i
believe um
and
what the media is gonna have to do is
they'll have to kind of do that with a
light touch
they'll be like speculation
it has been said
that perhaps
this was some type of blackmail up and
they they all have to pretend like they
don't know what any of it means you're
like people are saying this is
potentially a blackmail
operation that they would
uh compromise these powerful people
and videotape them doing things
that are heinous and immoral and illegal
and then hold that over their head to
gain control over them this is what's
being said we don't
we don't have any confirmation of this
we're not
but that's what it's the media's job the
media's job is to pretend
uh to be discovering things that peop
you've known for years
so that you'll know something for years
and then the media goes
it's perhaps
what you think
and you go yeah
but lady gizlane she's complaining about
being in jail she says a rat
sits next to her on the turlet
she says uh that uh
she's watched in the shower by prison
guards and had a rat
pet
she had a rat for company it is strange
um
falling from grace going
from uh
where she was
to
the brooklyn detention center you got to
think cause this is a woman who was
literally friends with kings and queens
and presidents and she really lived that
life
she was the real housewife of human
trafficking
truly
just a big goblet of white wine
pimping out hoes to prime ministers and
now she's rotting in a jail
cell and she's eating rotten food
they're giving her rotten food well she
says yeah apple with maggots in it
they're leaving the lights on so she
hasn't like been in the darkness in like
months and well
she is uh used to quite a different
mode of living right
and it's uh
she's not exactly somebody who can just
make an adjustment
which i think is inhumane to have her in
a jail cell like this i think you should
put her in a hotel
a five-star hotel
hot coffee
marble bathroom heated towels slippers
give her the internet
let her live a little
she just wants a fair trial she told the
newspaper i'm terrified the
overwhelmingly negative coverage will
poison my jury pool and affect the
outcome of my trial well i will be
honest that is true
many people have made their minds up
about her already i i can't deny that
that is very possible
people hear her name and there's an
image that comes into their mind
and it is an image of someone who's done
the wrong thing
um
but she'll have a trial and i don't know
how fair it'll be
i don't know how much they're gonna let
come out
she's not gonna roll
people think she's gonna roll
she's not gonna roll she knows if she
rolls and gets out it's all over for her
right and it's over for her family this
is the way the intelligence world works
it's not only you
it's your family it's anyone you've ever
cared about right she had a husband this
guy scott borginson
they lived in new hampshire look up this
guy
they got married he's acting like he
doesn't know who she is
oh yes scott borg it's an oxford mm-hmm
socialite business person he
now is like denying that he knows who
jaslane maxwell is yeah it says maybe
he's a fake husband is he has he been
invented
no he's real
and they were together
and then he was like wow yeah an article
for two weeks ago says he like
disappeared
yeah well he's
he's being like hounded by the press
and
they're like hey man
what's going on with your wife
and he does it you know
imagine that imagine being like yeah
my wife's having some problems like what
is it she's sick well
she's jizzling maxwell and they
discovered just laying on that estate
get up that house in uh new hampshire
she was in
because what a beautiful piece of
property
she was in we
we don't know if we want to see her get
out or not we want to see her get out if
she'll do the show she seems hopeful
like she'll just go back to her new
hampshire home like nothing ever
happened she wants part of me wants to
see that
part of me wants to see it
there it is
pretty
no she'll she's gonna get convicted and
she'll probably spend the rest of her
life in jail or she'll get killed or
whatever it's called tucked away her
retreat it's a sprawling one million
dollar retreat
it's nice
it's beautiful and that's where they
picked her up and they brought her to
the brooklyn detention center and who is
her lawyer who is representing chislane
maxwell who is
is it a high-powered
is it a woman
i think he should be a woman it should
be right i hope
we want jazlyn to have a fair trial and
have a good uh chance of getting off
apparently it's a guy who represented
one of bin laden's associates
not a great look
his name is sternheim he's a trial
lawyer
listen i told you
bin laden was clean
and this [ __ ] is also clean
i think she needs a woman but you know
what it's probably hard to get people to
take the case
it's probably difficult to get people to
take it's a hard because you really
gotta yas clean it up oh it is it is a
girl bobby sternheim is a girl yeah [ __ ]
yeah yeah nice google bobby sternheim
you need to yes queen it up you need to
be like this [ __ ]
was told to tell oh wow
well
well well well well
bobby sternheim is a woman
uh perhaps
but she is a tough
[ __ ] she looks like one of the prison
guards
at
the detention center yeah
but in order to win this case
if i if i was bobby sternheim
i would have to cut you've got to go up
there opening statements and be like
you know men they lie
they tell you things that aren't true
and you do you've ever been strung along
by a man
who tells you he loves you
but he just wants to [ __ ] kids
and blackmail the president
you know
oldest story in the book
man
men out there lying
and this young
inexperienced
daughter of uh
media mogul
who was
a sweet young innocent flower
didn't know the ways of the world
yes she was
practically royalty
yes her father owned a a a massive media
empire but so do i
so this poor young country farm girl
chislain maxwell this unsophisticated
british woman
gets
caught up
and influenced under the clutches of
this uh
figure jeffrey epstein the lawyers are
calling it the halo effect it is
the halo effect he surrounds himself
with people who would serve his needs he
surrounds himself with all these people
now this young unsophisticated it almost
seems like for her to get off they have
to turn her into something she's not
it's almost like she might rather just
die being a villain than having to be
this useful idiot this dupe
we have to convince the jury that you're
a [ __ ] that jeffrey so what you get
another few years before your tit falls
off
and you have your cancer anyway it's
like i get it you want to really go out
like that you want to convince the jury
that you're some idiot dupe who had no
idea what was going on that you were
taken advantage of i mean that's the
story they're gonna have to sell yeah
that's the narrative that they're gonna
have to sell
this man took advantage of a good woman
it's happened before and it'll happen
again you know bobby's sternum stein and
whatever sure her voice is quivering and
she's scaring the jury and her her voice
you know her just got her disgusting hot
coffee breath yelling at them i just ate
these
men they're robbing women
and and of their lives and you gotta
they gotta get the jury frothed up
in a real like [ __ ] jeffrey
jeffrey's a liar jeffrey told her things
that weren't true
he said he wanted to film fitness videos
on that island
he's a liar
and lady just laying well what the hell
was she supposed to do
we wish her the best
will they do a jizz lane maxwell sketch
on snl
i don't know about that
maybe they will shout out to everyone at
snl we're we're we kid
we love you all
we wish you the best
all right everybody thank you for
listening from the gas digital studio we
thank the great shannon shannon we love
you
shannon you're a great woman
we appreciate all your work who's that
other abroad natalie natalie
hello natalie thank both of you for
doing everything
you built this show natalie
you built this show
thank you i appreciate it you're welcome
you built this program
and we uh we appreciate we started here
at gas digital
and when we're thrown off the internet
and finally canceled we'll probably end
it here too
all right good luck everybody